Aujourd’hui, je ne fais rien.
Parfois, on dit « coincer la bulle »
ou tout simplement « buller ».
Mais d’où sort cette étrange expression ?
Quel lien entre l’oisiveté et la bulle ?
On cherche évidemment un rapport
avec un pré couvert de petites fleurs
La réponse se trouve bien dans un champ…
mais sur un champ de bataille.
Au milieu du XXe siècle, la précision d’un tir d’artillerie
nécessitait que la plateforme de l’engin
soit parfaitement à l’horizontal.
A l’époque, pas de GPS ni de laser.
Les militaires utilisaient un niveau.
Ils l’ajustaient jusqu’à ce que la bulle
soit coincée entre les 2 petits traits.
Une fois l’opération réussie, ils attendaient les ordres.
Pendant ce temps,
plus long qu’une « capsule de déconfiné »,
ils ne faisaient rien, si ce n’est jeter un œil
de temps en temps sur la bulle
pour vérifier qu’elle était bien coincée.
Pas bouger !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
j'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour et
pour être sûr de n'en rater aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés et on reste en lien.